if you're an introvert like me there is
good news because there are four highly
coveted skills that sets introverts
apart because our brains work
differently let's dive in one is that
introverts think more so one Harvard
study found that introvert's brains work
differently and have thicker gray matter
compared to extroverts in people who are
strongly introverted gray matter was
consistently thinner introverts also
showed more activity in the frontal
lobes where analysis and rational
thought take place two is that
introverts can focus for longer because
they enjoy spending time alone
introverts tend to be more willing than
extroverts to put in the hours alone
necessary to master a skill number three
is that introverts are often gifted in a
specific field so an average introverts
and extroverts are the same in terms of
intelligence but stats show that around
70 percent of gifted people are
introverts let's go number four is that
introverts do the right thing introverts
seem to be less swayed by external
events and driven more by their internal
moral compass so